es wird immer wieder darum gehen die
richtige balance zu finden einerseits
zwischen notwendigen einschränkungen zur
eindämmung des virus
andererseits unserem alltag der
weitergeht
fest steht der höhepunkt der ausbreitung
ist man nicht erreicht die lage in
unserem land ist sehr unterschiedlich
im kreis heinsberg ist sie aktuell eine
andere als etwa in der hansestadt
rostock
unsere strategie ist weiterhin die
ausbreitung von corona innerhalb
deutschlands und den betroffenen
regionen zu verlangsamen und einzudämmen
schon jetzt kommt es dabei zu
einschränkungen des alltags weil
öffentliche einrichtungen wie schulen
und kitas zeitweise geschlossen bleiben
unter weil großveranstaltungen etwa mit
internationalen publikum von den
zuständigen behörden abgesagt werden
dabei gilt immer der grundsatz die
sicherheit der bevölkerung geht im
zweifel vor
auch vor wirtschaftlichen interessen
[Applaus]